Is there a good protein product to use for the goal?
So yeah, I recommend the U.S. enzyme protein mixes
because they're low in glutamine.
There are some protein mixes that have higher glutamine.
I also trust U.S. enzymes because I think of all
the supplement companies out there, U.S. enzymes, and PRL are probably the two clearest
beating that they're the most anal companies as far as protecting their clients with
purity.
So most supplements, you know, the supplement companies have to buy their raw product from
some place.
And whether you like it or not, a lot of raw product is purchased from China.
All the green tea extract, all the EGCG extract in every supplement is there's not made
anywhere but China.
And you know, these producers in China will basically be, you know, discriminate to who
they send their clearest stuff to.
So if they send a giant barrel, it comes actually in these giant bags on a pallet.
They send a pallet of green tea extract EGCG to U.S. enzymes or PRL.
They test the batch, not just the top of the batch, but they test all the way through the
batch.
And if it doesn't, if it tests contaminated at all, it gets sent back and the way they have
the contract with the company is that they don't have to pay for the shipping in an excise
and everything so they don't ever want to get a batch back.
So clean products are important to me.
I know other companies, you know, do testing as well and that we only sell, we only recommend
companies that we feel like are the clearest.
And that's a difference between if you bought your supplements at Walmart or Walgreens or Target
or something like that.
So you want clean supplements, but then when you're looking at a protein powder for a cancer
patient, you want a protein powder that has the least amount of glutamated in it.
And we've settled out the U.S. enzymes product for that for protein.
They have a chocolate and they have a vanilla, it's very good.
We use it a lot and a lot of people like it.
But you know what I've said about protein powders in the past, that's why this person asked
this question for how to go, is that you're only still getting 20 to 25 grams of protein
in a protein powder drink, which is far less than you get from a piece of chicken.
So it's really hard to get your protein levels up by just assuming a protein powder.
But I understand if you're on the go, you want to add a little bit of protein to a shake
or something, there's nothing wrong with adding a protein powder, you get that little bit
of boost, I would use the protein powder from U.S. enzymes.